hey little guys my name is Deshawn oh
and today we're going to talk about
linking so what is linking what does the
simple spot linker actually do linking
is a process that we go through when we
go from our source surface plus files to
our actual executable binary so the
first stage is actually compiling our
source files and I actually made an
entire video on that so go check that
out link in the description below
once we've compiled our files we need to
go through a process called linking now
the primary focus of linking is to find
where each symbol and function is and
link them together remember each file is
compiled into a separate object file as
a translation unit and they have no
relation to each other those files can't
actually interact so if we decide to
split our program across multiple C++
files which is of course very common we
need a way to actually link those files
together into one program and that is
the primary purpose of what the linker
does even if you don't have functions in
external files like for example you've
written your entire program in one file
the application still needs to know
where the entry point is so in other
words where the main function is so that
when you actually run your application
the C runtime library can say hey here's
the main function I'm going to jump
there and start executing code from
there and that is effectively what
starts with your application so it still
needs to link the main function and
everything like that even if you don't
have all the files the best way to
explain this is by showing some examples
so let's jump over and take a look so
here in Visual Studio we've got a very
simple project that just contains one
source file master tbp and inside there
we have two functions log and multiply
the multiply function actually calls the
log function prints out the word
multiply to the console and then returns
a times B pretty simple stuff however
this isn't an actual application since
of course it doesn't contain a main
function the first thing that you have
to realize is that there are those two
stages of compilation right there's
compiling and there's linking and
there's actually a way that you can
differentiate between the two individual
studio if you press ctrl f7 or if you
press the compile button only
compilation will happen no linking will
ever happen
however if you build your project or if
you hit f5 to run your project it will
actually compile and then link so if I
just hit ctrl f7 you'll see that I
actually get no errors everything's fine
because the compilation was successful
it generated that math dot obj file the
object file and everything's great
however if I right-click on my project
and hit build you'll see that I actually
get a linking error entry-point must be
defined and again that's because I'm
missing my entry point my main function
so because our compilation is divided
into those two stages compiling and
linking we actually get different types
of error messages associated with each
stage if I make a syntax error for
example which of course is something the
compiler has to deal with if I compile
my code you'll see that it tells me that
I actually get an error which is called
c2 143 and then it says syntax error of
course so this is the error code for
this type of error and you'll notice
that it actually starts with the letter
C this tells us that it's an error that
occurred in the compiling stage if I fix
that and then build my entire project
you'll see the error code listed here
begins with the letters Ln K which of
course stamps a link and it even tells
us over here that this happened during
the link stage it's really important
that you know what kind of error you get
whether it's a compiling error or a
linking error because of course you need
to know that so that you can fix it
properly so in this case we get an error
which tells us the entry point must be
defined again that is because we are
compiling this as an application if we
go to our properties and we take a look
at what configuration type we have set
here you'll see it is data application
or exe and every exe file has to have
some kind of entry point if we go over
here into the linker settings and into
advanced you'll actually see that we can
specify a custom entry point the entry
point doesn't have to be the main
function there just has to be an entry
point now normally it is the main
function and for pretty much anything
you do it probably will be the main
function but just so you know entry
point doesn't necessarily have to be a
function called main it can be really
anything so if we back out of here and
actually write that main function I'll
just write int main and then I'll build
my project again you'll see that we no
longer get that linking error and that
we were successfully able to generate
that exe file all right so now that
we've established that let's go ahead
and print out the value of that multiply
function so we'll multiply 5 and 8
together
so what we should see is this message
being logged and then the value 40 being
printed let's also add a CNCs so that
our console doesn't close immediately
then I'll just click on this local
windows debugger button to run this and
you can see we get multiplied and 40 so
our application seems to be running
correctly great now suppose I had these
in multiple files for example this log
doesn't really need to be in this mass
file because of course this just logs
the message so why don't I have a
separate file that actually contains all
of my logging related functions I'm
going to right click on source files and
add a new C++ file called lock they'll
typically and then I'll click Add I'm
going to grab that log function from
here and move it into my log Delta VP
file if I go back to master CBP and try
and compile this code I'll get an error
and you'll know that this is a compile
error because the error code begins with
let us see telling me the log is not
found because this file has no knowledge
that a function called log exists at all
so we'll go ahead and grab this first
line of the log function which is the
signature and we'll add this so that we
have a declaration of the log function
in this map dot CPP file no ctrl f7 and
you can see it as compiling worked now
let's go ahead and build our entire
project we get several errors here
compile errors telling us the CR is not
found because we need to actually
include iostream once we've done that
let's build our entire project
alright great it seemed to work
successfully now let's take a look at
one type of linking error that we might
get this one called unresolved external
symbol and this is what happens when the
linker can't find something that it
needs so we'll go back over here and in
the log file I'm going to change this to
say something else for example I'm just
going to add an R here so that we say
logger if I go back to master CPP I
still left my declaration as log so it
still does expect the function to be
called log so this file will still
compile of course because this does no
linking so all it's doing is checking to
make sure everything here compiled
correctly it believes that there is a
log function somewhere but it's going to
be the job of the linking stage to
actually find that log function so if I
build my entire project now you'll see
we actually get an error this is a
linking error because if you can see
that it begins
with the LNK letters and the RS as
unresolved external symbol now he tells
us exactly what symbol is missing it's
that log function it even tells us where
we reference it that we're referencing
it in a function called multiply so here
it is in multiply we're calling log and
it cannot actually find which function
to link it to so of course it has to
give up an error because when we land on
that code at runtime
what is it supposed to do when it tries
to call the log function it doesn't know
where the log function is now if I go
over here and I comment out this log
function so that we actually never call
it if I try and build this we get no
errors the reason this happens because I
never call the log function so the
linker doesn't have to link this
function call to actually call the log
function because we never call the log
function another interesting note is
that if I do call the log function here
and multiply however I comment this line
out so that I never call multiply which
in turn never calls log if I build my
project now you'll see that I still get
a linking error and you might be like
what but why is that happening
I'm not calling multiply anywhere why is
it complaining about a linking error
Trinette have just removed a function
entirely since this potentially dead
code that's never used
wrong because whilst we're not using the
multiply function in this file we
actually could technically use it in
another file and so the linker does
actually need to link that if we could
somehow tell the compiler that hey this
function multiplied I'm only ever going
to use it inside this file then of
course we could remove that linking
necessity since this multiplies never
called it never needs to call log oh
wait there is a way we could do that if
we come over here and write the word
static in front of multiply that
basically means that this multiply
function is only declared for this
translation unit which is this math dot
CPP file in our case and since multiply
is never called inside this file if I
build we won't get any linking errors if
I bring back my comment though and then
I build of course we will get a linking
error in this case we actually ended up
modifying the name of the function
however it's not just the name of the
function that matters if I bring back to
function I'll call it log again I'll
build my project we won't get any errors
but then I for example change the return
type to be int and then I'll just return
0 or something like
if I build my project now you'll see
that we get an error because in master
CBP we specify that this log function
was a void function and so because of
that is going to look for a function
called log that returns void and also
takes in this one parameter if I go back
to log and I might change this back to
avoid get rid of this return zero and
build it everything works fine but then
I might add another parameter for
example the level if I now build this
we'll get a linking error once again
because the log function that it expects
does not have another parameter you'll
see if we go down here into the linking
error message it actually expects a
function which returns void which has
this calling convention it's called log
and it has to have just one parameter
which is a constant that's it if they
cannot find exactly that then you're
going to get a linking error let's go
back over here to our log file and just
remove this level so that our program
works again and if I build it of course
we shouldn't get any linking errors
great okay so the other type of linking
error that's pretty common is when we
have to look at symbols so in other
words we have functions or variables
which have the same name and the same
signature so two identically named
functions which have the same return
value and the same parameters if that
happens we're in trouble
the reason we're in trouble is because
the linker doesn't know which one to
link to it's ambiguous so back in our
code if I was for example to write
another version of dysfunction so I'll
just literally copy and paste this
function and try and build my code
you'll know that we actually get a
compile error because this already has a
body and the compiler can kind of tell
us that yeah okay since I'm compiling
this file I can obviously see that
you've made a mistake this code just
isn't valid so this is an example of
having to look at symbols where the
compiler can actually save us because
this all happens in one file and no
linking actually needs to happen to see
that we've got an error however if I was
to move this into a different file for
example I'll move it back into our math
file right over here so we still have
our declaration I can leave that there
that's fine that's just a declaration
where they have one definition of log in
this file so it's not going to give us a
compiling error if I had control f7 just
to compile this you can see it's totally
fine but now if I build we get a linking
error
and you can see that the one we get it
tells us that we have this log function
already defined in log obj one or more
multiply defined symbols found so in
this case link it doesn't know which log
function to link to does the link to the
one in map specifically or does link to
the one in log dot CBP it doesn't know
now you might think that this type of
arrow is not something that would happen
often and that you're smarter than that
however this can creep up on you so I'll
show you a few ways as to how that can
happen
all right firstly let's just remove this
extra log definition we have here so
that our project builds successfully now
let's create a header file I'm going to
right click on the header file select
add new item going to be a header file
I'm going to call this file log H and
click Add now inside here I'm going to
grab this log function and make sure
that I'm declaring it inside this header
file if I go back to log CPP I'll write
some kind of other function for example
in its log that's just going to call the
log function and say that it's
initialized the log of course if we try
and compile now we're going to get an
error because we need that log function
so I'll include log back over here in
master zbp instead of having this
declaration here I'm also going to
include log so great we're calling a log
function from both the multiply function
inside the master zerah key file as well
as the net log inside the log of CBP
file it doesn't really matter that I'm
not calling this function so don't worry
about that I'm just going to build my
project okay check this out I get an
error telling me the log is already
defined in local obj so we get a one or
more multiply divine symbol sound so
we're getting a duplicate symbols error
message however you can see that I've
really only got one definition of log
it's inside this log dot H file why is
it complaining about multiple symbols
now this comes back to how the include
statement works remember when we include
a header file we're just taking the
contents of that header file and putting
it where our include statement is so
what's actually happened is it's taking
this log function popped it over here
like so into logged up CBP and then also
over here and now you can see that we of
course do have to log functions so how
do we fix this well we've got a few
options here if we undo all of this so
that we are including log again we could
mark this log function
static that means that the linking that
should happen to this log function
should only be internal which means that
this log function when it gets included
into log dog therapy and master therapy
is going to be just internal to this
file kind of like what we did with
multiply so basically log and math will
have their own versions of this function
called log and it won't be visible to
any other object files so if we just
compile this now you'll see that we
won't get any linking errors another
thing that we could do to this is make
it inline of course in line just means
that it's going to take our actual
function body and replace the call with
it so in this case this log initialized
log would just become that it saw we
were to do something like that and build
you'll see that we get no errors either
now there's one other way that we could
fix this and that's probably what I
would do in this situation and that is
just move the definition of this into
one translation unit because right now
what's happening is this log function is
being included in two translation units
love does EBP and maps are therapy
that's what's causing the error in the
first place so we could move it into a
third translation unit or we could put
this log definition into one of these
existing translation units since this
function is called log and it's related
to logging I'm actually going to put it
into log dot CBP so I'll grab this
function I'll copy it into logical
sweetie I'll get rid of the in line and
then I'll come back to my log door age
and just leave the Declaration here
again without the in line of course so
now this header file just has the
declaration for log the actual function
to link to is included inside logo CBP
once in one translation unit in our
project and then main we'll call that so
if I build this we get no linking errors
and our project was able to be linked
successfully so that's it that's pretty
much a quick crash course on linking and
how linking works remember at the end of
the day the linker needs to take all of
our objects files that were generated
during compilation and link them all
together it will also pull in any other
libraries that we may be using for
example the C runtime library the
sippers law standard library our
platform api is necessary and a whole
lot of other stuff it's very common to
be linking from many different places
there's also different types of linking
we have static linking and we have
dynamic linking but I'll save that for
another video anyway thanks for watching
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
have any other questions just leave them
in the comments
and below and I'll try my best to answer
them be sure to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and if you really like this
video you can support me on patreon
that'll help me make more of these
videos and by doing so you'll also get
access to early draft videos and be
involved in the planning process but as
always I'll see you guys next time
goodbye fool